-Performing "Telepatía"
from her album
"Sin Miedo
(del Amor y Otros Demonios)"
here is Kali Uchis.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ Quién lo diría ♪
♪ Que se podría hacer
el amor por telepatía ♪
♪ La luna está llena,
mi cama vacía ♪
♪ Lo que yo te haría ♪
♪ Si te tuviera de frente
la mente te la volaría ♪
♪ De noche y de día,
de noche y de día ♪
♪ You know I'm just
a flight away ♪
♪ If you wanted you can take
a private plane ♪
♪ A kilómetros estamos
conectando ♪
♪ Y me prendes aunque no me
estés tocando ♪
♪ You know I got a lot to say ♪
♪ All these voices in the
background of my brain ♪
♪ Y me dicen todo
lo que estás pensando ♪
♪ Me imagino lo que ya estás
maquinando ♪
♪ Quién lo diría ♪
♪ Que se podría hacer
el amor por telepatía ♪
♪ La luna está llena,
mi cama vacía ♪
♪ Lo que yo te haría ♪
♪ Si te tuviera de frente
la mente te la volaría ♪
♪ De noche y de día,
de noche y de día ♪
♪ [ Vocalizes ] ♪
♪ You know that I can see
right through you ♪
♪ I can read your mind,
I can read your mind ♪
♪ What you want to do
ooh-ooh-ooh, ooh-ooh-ooh ♪
♪ It's written all over
your face times two ♪
♪ 'Cause I can read your mind
I can read your mind ♪
♪ I can hear your thoughts
like a melody ♪
♪ Listen while you talk when
you're fast asleep ♪
♪ You stay on the phone
just to hear me breathe ♪
♪ On repeat ♪
♪ Quién lo diría ♪
♪ Que se podría hacer
el amor por telepatía ♪
♪ La luna está llena,
mi cama vacía ♪
♪ Lo que yo te haría ♪
♪ Si te tuviera de frente
la mente te la volaría ♪
♪ De noche y de día,
de noche y de día ♪
♪♪
Thank you.